all right I think I'm live I took the
advice of someone on the last stream
instead of not knowing when I'm live
they said just put up an image to start
with and then you'll know in your life
and then you can switch to yourself
which is exactly what I did mmm
excuse me um excuse me jeez having a
FoxNews moment here so I'm I started
like a minute early because I'm going to
be taking the so I side with and the
link is in the description has updated
there I guess you'd call it like a voter
quiz or an election quiz or something
like that they've updated it to reflect
2020 and most of the 2020 candidates
that are running so I'm going to be the
title of the stream is something like
who's the most progressive candidate of
them all for 2020 and it's not exactly
about that today but it's sort of is I
couldn't think of exactly what to call
it but I'm gonna be taking that quiz and
I've said already a little bit about who
I would be more likely to support based
on the current candidates and I figure
what better thing to do then to take
this quiz and see exactly where it all
shakes out so I'm gonna get to that in a
moment the link is in the stream
description so what I would suggest you
could do this if you want or you don't
have to take the test along with me and
then after we're done I don't know maybe
super chat me your results and we'll see
who is in the what type of people are in
the livestream audience today okay so
we'll get to that momentarily
this if this is your first youtube
channel livestream that with me I'm
guessing your you've seen YouTube live
at some point before in your life it's
really live unless it's a replay these
are not like the video clips that we
upload this is actually me talking to
you now live unless this is a replay you
can use super chat to ask questions and
to send comments and I now have the
ability to put those up on the screen
which is cool so if you sign up for a
YouTube
membership that will pop up if you send
a super chap that will also pop up so
that's cool send those and I will get to
those sign up for membership to
different coupon codes in the
description you will get alive thank you
from me and I will open the phones if we
get 10 new members and sometimes people
get mad they say David why are you
holding the phone lines hostage why are
you only opening the phone lines during
the live stream if you get some number
of new members the reason is it cost
money to take phone calls so we actually
have a system which allows us to have I
think it's up to one or two hundred
people simultaneously holding but we pay
for a per minute per person on hold so
when we often have during these streams
forty or fifty people who are holding
for ten minutes that's five hundred
minutes so right when I get this gift
every time we're done with a live stream
where as soon as I'm done and I shut the
phone system off I get an email saying
your account has been recharged with a
charge on our credit card for however
many people have called in and talked to
me so that's why okay I will open the
phone lines after taking the quiz if we
get 10 new members it's cheap there's
discount codes in the description please
don't troll the live chat and we also
now are part of a YouTube beta program
called channel membership you can use
the join button and when you do that
your name will also pop up here just
like Frank Fisher and Frank cable and
stage maker and mr. Fred AG or Fred AG
all of whom are now david pakman show
YouTube channel members so I'm gonna get
into this voter guide momentarily I
think it's important to mention a couple
of things I don't think this will be
that notable in terms of the results
unless there is like a huge difference
for me with one candidate versus the
other so like if I take this and it says
77% Bernie and 76% Elizabeth Warren and
75% tulsi gabbard I don't know that
that's hugely
in the sense that when you choose
answers here as you'll see it asks you
how important is this to you and I'm
making my best guess if I mark something
as more versus most important that could
be the difference between 1% more for
one candidate or another so what I'm
going to be looking for is are my
politics significantly more aligned with
one of the presidential candidates than
than the others a couple points
difference I don't think will be that
interesting the other thing that I think
is important to mention here is that the
way this is done draws on a combination
of voting records for prop for people
who are already elected officials
campaign platform public statements and
so we have to kind of realize that with
someone like Julian Castro for example
the way in which a website like this
assesses where he is
is based on different information than
for example someone like Elizabeth
Warren who's been in the Senate for a
while now or someone like Tulsi Gabbard
who has been in the House of
Representatives so that's the other
thing we there there maybe these are
approximations ok so what I'm looking
for here is do I come out drastically
more for one candidate than for another
so maybe I should just get started I
don't know if people are people already
I'm seeing a lot of a lot of chatting
going on no super chats yet so maybe I
will just get into it and then we'll see
what what other kind of trouble we get
up to during the live stream so let's
just start and again my recommendation
is do this along with me link is in the
description and super chat me your
results when we're done first question
should the president be able to
authorize military force against
al-qaida without congressional approval
that that's it pretty clear no for me I
mean I look at the other stances it's
like an even stronger yes/no Congress
should approve all military conflicts
what's the difference between no and no
Congress should approve all military
conflicts I guess the question is
al-qaeda versus all military conflicts
I'm just gonna leave it as a no and I
will rank this as
some water this is a more important
issue to me should the United States
assassinate suspected terrorists in
foreign countries yes or no yes but only
if there's undeniable evidence they're
planning to attack our country that's
complex because undeniable according to
WHO yes but only if there is undeniable
evidence that they have committed an
attack against our country no they
should be captured and given a fair
trial I don't know about the legality of
that no capture interrogate and imprison
them instead do we have jurisdiction
this is a complicated one because in
principle I believe the United States
should not assassinate suspected
terrorists in foreign countries in the
way that this entire program of
extraordinary rendition has functioned
at the same time that that's sort of
like what war is and I do recognize that
if a country is attacked by another
country that they eat even according to
the Geneva Convention they are allowed
to retaliate so is a hard no my position
when you consider I mean assassination
is different than a declaration of war I
think I'm gonna keep it simple and go
with a no but leave it as somewhat
important based on the wording social
issues what is your stance stance on
abortion I am pro-choice and I consider
this a more important issue should the
government continue to fund Planned
Parenthood absolutely let's see what
else is said here as long as funding is
not for abortion procedures now I don't
agree with that yes services reach
beyond abortions well that's true but I
don't know that I need to go into detail
the noes don't make sense to me so I'm
just gonna say yes and this is a some I
mean some what makes it seem like I
don't care about Planned Parenthood but
I think in total this is not unlike my
top five political issues so I'll say
some what do you support the
legalization of same-sex marriage of
course I do it's been legalized so I
guess I'll just mark this as somewhat
important environmental issues should
the government increase environmental
regulations to prevent climate change
it's a yes for me yes and provide
incentives for alternative energy
production
uh I think this is a stronger yes than
simply yes yes and we should be
incentivizing and I think that this is
one of the most important issues right
now if we're underwater
due to climate change if you can't
breathe out in public because of climate
change it's gonna be hard to be an
activist for any issue should the u.s.
withdraw from the Paris climate
agreement no so I'm gonna put no and
this is I mean climate is one of the
most important issues the Paris climate
agreement itself is is the second tier
issue relative to the big picture of
climate so am i I think I would still
call it most because it's it's just a
major issue right now should the
government give tax credits and
subsidies to the wind power industry yes
yes wind power is the best alternative
to coal and natural gas yes the
government should support more
sustainable energy technologies I'm just
gonna go with the yes and this is a very
important issue to me okay economic
issues should the government make cuts
to public spending in order to reduce
the national debt no not for that reason
yes and no yes and increased taxes yes
and eliminate federal agencies that are
unconstitutional give me a break
yes but by drastically reducing benefits
and salaries of government officials no
reduce military spending instead see the
problem with this question is that it
assumes that merely for the sake of it
reducing the national debt is an
important thing and we've talked about
how there is a lot of nonsense
surrounding debt and deficit which
doesn't make a lot of sense
so I'm trying to sort of infer what's
implied by my answer here I mean I guess
the answer is no I don't think public
spending should be cut merely to reduce
the national debt and I I do think that
we should reduce military spending but
not instead so I think with the word
install of these instead I think I'm
going to not not get involved in and
just put this as a as a somewhat maybe
it's even a more important issue should
the US raise taxes on the rich yes no
yes
and raise taxes on all income brackets
reform to a flat tax that's a no-no but
lowers taxes for the poor no keep the
current tax structure lower the income
tax rate and remove all loopholes for
large corporations abolish the income
tax net so now ok so I in general I'm a
yes person on this I think that we
should raise taxes on on the very rich
the problem I have is I actually don't
think raising taxes is completely
necessary if we were to reorganize our
spending priorities with the tax revenue
that we already collect and if we were
to lift the cap on social security
contributions above 121 or 123 thousand
wherever it is right now so I'm not a no
person under many circumstances I would
raise taxes on the rich but at the same
time I feel like we could keep the
current tax structure and actually fix
the problems we have if we stopped the
defense spending to the extent that we
do it and military so I'm sort of unsure
how to maybe I don't need to overthink
it should the u.s. raise taxes on the
rich I think that there should be a
higher tax bracket that exists so I'll
just make it a yes but markets somewhat
important should businesses be required
to provide paid leave for full-time
employees during the birth of a child or
sick family member my instinct is yes
but I wonder yes but only for companies
with over a hundred employees I think a
hundred is too high of a threshold but I
do think there should be some threshold
if you think of a mom-and-pop with three
employees or something like that the
they are going to need to hire someone
else if an employee is a way four months
of for maternity leave and they could
literally go out of business by having
to pay for both the employee that's not
working and someone that they hire but a
hundred employees is just way too high
of a threshold that should probably be
more like half that or maybe even a
little less I guess I'm going to put
I mean I guess I'll put yes but for
companies with a hundred employees
knowing that that's not the right
threshold for me but just a flat yes is
also not the right thing for me and I'll
market is somewhat important should
Internet Service Providers be allowed to
speed up access to popular websites that
pay higher rates so it's a net
neutrality question it's a definite no
and I would simply say it's a flat now
and for me this is one of the most
important issues if as I said before the
way most of us learn about what's going
on in the world and know about which
issues we want to activate around is
because of media coverage which is
directly impacted by net neutrality so
that's a no should there be more
restrictions on the current process of
purchasing a gun yes yes and ban all
guns for public use can't do that yes
but only by closing the gun show
loophole nope background checks are
needed
yes requires strict background checks
psychological testing and training so am
i a flat yes or a yes in these ways I
guess I'm a yes in these particular ways
and this is a more important issue to me
should teachers be allowed to carry guns
at schools so I don't believe that
teachers should be armed as a matter of
policy however I do think that the law
in some places would dictate that if you
are licensed that you can't be of course
if the school is designated a gun-free
zone then this doesn't apply but can the
school can the school if it's not the
case can the school as a policy I'm just
gonna say teachers should not be allowed
to carry guns at school
period I mean that I think that that's
the simplest way here should health
insurers be allowed to deny coverage to
individuals with a pre-existing
condition no and this is one of the most
important issues if you're not healthy
if you don't have access to care doesn't
matter whether education or abortion or
space travel is most important to you
hard to be an activist if you don't have
access to health care should the
government increase funding for mental
health research and treatment yes now
there's this option yes but only
increase funding for personalised care
instead of subsidizing pharmaceutical
companies well I don't think that that's
that's a sort of a false dichotomy I'm
gonna go with yes and I think that this
is a
more important issue should the
government regulate the prices of
life-saving drugs yes and we should
socialized medicine and healthcare most
important issue absolutely do I support
increasing taxes for the rich in order
to reduce interest rates for student
loans no I mean I don't support doing it
for that reason and the interest rates
on student loans are actually not even
in the top certainly not the top three
maybe not even the top five problems
with the education system no but we
should still reduce interest rates I
just think as asked no I don't think
that that's why we should raise taxes do
I support common core national standards
I don't actually I think the most
applicable is no my state's current
standards exceed the common core
standards and I think maybe make more
sense as well I'm just gonna leave this
as somewhat important do I support
charter schools you know I actually I do
conditionally let's see if we have yes
but not at the expense of funding public
schools I have studied this issue quite
a bit and I am of the mindset that
charter schools in and of themselves are
not the problem and actually the
existence of charter schools can provide
really interesting and valuable
opportunities for students who learn in
other ways or have other areas of
interest but the Republican way of
pushing them which is to decimate
funding for Pratt for public schools is
absolutely and completely unacceptable
so definitely I I think it cannot be at
the expense of funding public schools
and maybe that's a more important issue
should the u.s. remain in the United
Nations yes I can't think of anything
here that that would apply more yes but
scale back yes and use the peacekeeping
forces to protect our interests No so
I'm going to say yes I think that this
is a more important issue should every
eighteen-year-old citizen be required to
provide at least one year of military
service it's a no-no service should be a
choice instead of an obligation I'm
comfortable with just know should the
u.s. accept refugees from
Syria in principle yes I don't think
Syria should be singled out yes yes we
should accept 10,000 I don't know that
number is not I don't know why that
would be the number yes but only except
family is no single Muslim and yes but
we should accept much more than 10,000
I'm not sure on the number yes but only
after extensive background checks and
monitoring to ensure they have no
terrorist connections I mean yeah that's
that I agree with that but we do vetting
already regardless of where they're from
so I'm gonna say yes and and Mark it
kind of in the middle should police
officers be required to wear body
cameras I'm in favor of that should
convicted criminals have the right to
vote they should yes except for felons
convicted of murder or violent crimes
yes but only after completing their
sentences and parole probation so my
instinct is to just say yes on this I've
heard some competitively compelling
arguments that once you that it should
be once you've completed your sentence
but I just think I'm a YES on that issue
should prisons ban the use of solitary
confinement for juveniles yes should a
photo ID be required to vote yes yes
this will prevent voter fraud no one
there's little evidence that voter fraud
exists no and automatically register
every citizen to vote when they're 18 no
this will disadvantage those who do not
have the resources to obtain one all
three of these provisions apply little
evidence that it exists we should do
automatic registration and it will
disadvantage people who can't afford
even if the photo ID is free very often
the documents you need in order to get
the ID or not so I think I'm just a hard
no and this is a very important issue
should the Electoral College be
abolished yes and switch to a ranked
voting system I think is where I am no
reform yeah I'm gonna go with yes and
it's a more important issue should
foreigners residing in the US have the
right to vote yes or no yes but only
after five years yes but only after ten
years anyone who pays taxes should have
the right to vote yes but not in local
elections yes but only
in local elections no only legal
citizens should be allowed to vote you
know I'm actually unsure about this one
again it's one of these where my my
immediate reaction is voting is for
citizens but then there are really good
reasons to let people who live here on a
permanent basis vote even if they're not
citizen so I think for today I'm going
to go with yes in local elections and
market somewhat important and I'm sort
of open to having my mind being pushed
even further on this should the
government increase spending on public
transit yes yes and provide more free
public transit yes but only towards
environmentally friendly solutions hmm
all of these are good options I think
I'm just gonna say yes and market more
important should the US build a wall
along the southern border the answer is
no but let's see what else is here no
too costly and ineffective no we should
adopt open borders no but increased the
military presence I'm just a no should
children of illegal immigrants be
granted legal citizenship I think yes
yes if they were born here we'll know
that that's the whole point yes and
abolish borders no yes but don't grant
parents citizenship yes but after four
years of military service or college I'm
gonna say yes and I think that this is a
C it's a it is a more important issue
but in the grand scheme of things it it
relates to a small portion of the
population which doesn't mean it's
unimportant but I think in this context
I'll mark it as someone should
immigrants be deported if they commit a
serious crime does that mean legal legal
immigrants yes no yes after they
finished their sentence yes as long as
it's safe for them to return no only if
they have entered the country illegally
yeah absolutely committing a crime if
you're here legally should not
jeopardize that immigration status
should the government require children
to be vaccinated for preventable
diseases I think that if they have to go
to public school no but require
vaccinations to attend public school no
fund public ad campaigns about the risks
and benefits instead I mean I would
support that no but hold parents
criminally liable
for transferring deadly diseases to
other children that's extraordinarily
dicey I'm going to say no but require
vaccination should producers be required
to label genetically engineered foods
thing about this is I mean I think this
is my view right here we have
selectively bred crops for thousands of
years and labeling adds an unfounded
stigma to the science I know that there
are people in my audience who don't
agree with me on this but I have studied
this issue for a long time and
interviewed some of the top experts on
it and I have found no evidence that GMO
food on the basis of being GMO is
actually unhealthy and that while there
are differences between the type of
selective breeding that has been done
for a long time and some of the new
types of genetic modification it's
really the pesticides and herbicides
that are problematic and the ways in
which some of these crops are
particularly engineered by big big
agriculture can be problematic but GMO
in and of itself
I've still not seen any evidence and
that completely debunked rat study by
the way don't even mention that to me so
I actually am going to go with no on
this but I don't consider it to be a
hugely important issue should the
government fund space travel yes yes and
drastically increased NASA's current
budget or just a yes I think we should
increase NASA's budget there we go
okay so I've not there are like
additional questions that I can get to
oh well the nuclear energy one is
interesting I would say I actually am
okay with nuclear energy but only as a
bridge ah here is my position yes
temporarily while we increase investment
into cleaner renewable alternatives let
me see if there's any other additional
questions that I might want to answer
should Muslim immigrants be banned from
entering the country until the
government improves its ability to
screen out potential terrorists no I
don't think so
should illegal immigrants have access to
government subsidized health care yes no
yes if they pay taxes yes and grant them
citizenship yes but to port them after
treatment yes but only for
life-threatening emergencies and no the
kids man this is this is
much more complex than this question
purports to be I mean I think the answer
is yes because we figured out how it's
so much more expensive to have emergency
rooms used as primary care so maybe I'll
just say yes and mark it in the middle
let's see what other extra questions
there might be more electoral questions
should there be a limit to the amount of
money a candidate can receive from a
donor yes there should and that is a
very important issue should foreign
lobbyists be allowed to raise money for
American elections I think the answer is
no that we should keep American
elections American to the extent that we
can should the minimum voting age be
lowered um I don't know I think that I
think that it's okay where it is yes and
voters should pass a test I would love
that but I think it would not be a
constitutional okay that's probably
enough electoral questions to get a
pretty good sense
all right let's leave it there and see
where I am who I'm not gonna answer that
right now all right let's get to my
results it's tabulating my results and
we will see where this comes out okay
and before we we show the results let me
mention again I said at the beginning
we're taking the I side with political
test that's now been updated to reflect
2020 candidates the way this is put
together is from different sources for
each candidate so Richard Oh Jettas
positions are differently ascertained
than someone like Kamala Harris or
Elizabeth Warren or whatever because
some people have been in the US Senate
some members of Congress who Leon Castro
was mayor and HUD secretary so in some
senses you know do we go with how do you
weigh the strength of Elizabeth Warren's
foreign policy on the basis of her
Senate votes versus Richard o Jettas
foreign policy merely on the basis of
what he tells us because he's been a
West Virginia state senator and doesn't
really vote on foreign policy I don't
know the answer to that so as I said
before we we get to my results here
momentarily I think that this will be
interesting only if it shows like a
drastic difference between one candidate
and all of the others but if they're
very close
I think that it's not necessarily going
going to tell us that much okay let's
switch over and see what my results are
my 2020 presidential ballot based on
your political beliefs this is how you
side with the potential candidates in
the future 2020 presidential election
Andrew yang former guest on the David
Pakman show
eighty-eight percent agreement with my
policy number two Kirsten Gillibrand who
I've said has no shot
and number three Elizabeth Warren at 84%
Oh Jenna at 83 that is very very
interesting Kamala Harris Julian Castro
Tulsi Gabbard all at 82 joe biden and
bernie at 81 and 8800 prah Michelle
Obama John Delaney hey I have more than
50% agreement with Mitt Romney there's
something interesting okay and furthest
away his pension Piro and Ted Cruz oh
that is just the best okay so this is
very very interesting I should have
Andrew Yang back on the program he
andrew yang is running primarily as the
ubi universal basic income candidate and
he I mean I would love to say that the
guy has a shot and I would quite frankly
with peace and love talk to him about
the fact that I think he has no shot but
I am not that surprised that when you
include him I agree with almost
everything that that he was telling us
now the only funny thing about this is
it says socialism here he's not a
socialist he's a a sort of social
democrat entrepreneur type and that's
sort of what i aligned with but for
whatever reason based on my answers and
the I side with dot-coms assessment of
his policies it has us on the same page
when it comes to socialism which is sort
of odd so anyway I think that this is
not perfect but I'm not really surprised
about Andrew yang or Elizabeth Warren
kirsten gillibrand here is a bit
surprising
particularly when Keynesian is there for
her and not for
Elizabeth Warren Oh Jenna at 83 is a
little bit weird and then all of these
others are okay they are what they are
so I I think what we're kind of learning
here is that a lot of these candidates
so far on a plurality of issues are
basically the same and that the
differences are coming down to a few
percentage points at least on the basis
of this assessment and what I take away
from this is that my view that in the
end we have a lot of candidates all of
whom would be much better than what we
have going on right now in the white
house I'm extra comfortable with that
given given the results of this test so
start sending super chats let me know
how you did on this I will start getting
to people's questions and comments which
we will put up on the screen now let me
adjust that just a little bit I will as
I mentioned open up the phone lines if
we get new patrons or members I think I
have the let's see if I have the
membership thing so whenever we open up
the phone lines it costs us money
because that's just how it works and I
would love it if we got ten new patrons
or members during the live stream we
have one so far Ann Handley and Hanley
has become a new patron at patreon.com
slash david pakman show we have two
coupon codes available for you okay go
to david pakman.com slash membership
pick a monthly or yearly membership drag
the red slider wherever you want and
then on the second page after hitting
the sign-up button you'll notice where
there is a coupon code field now this
coupon code that's on screen vote soon
18 this is an old coupon code okay we
have much bigger and better things here
that I will I will keep you abreast of
if you put in the coupon code this is 20
20 this is to zero to zero you will see
that you can save 40% off of any
membership okay
this makes a $6 a month membership a
little over $3 a month most of our
audience can afford that if you can't
don't worry about it I don't want you to
support what we're doing if 3 dollars
and 60 cents a month is affordable
please consider making a new membership
on our website if you want like the
blockbuster deal of the year
select the $60 membership on the first
part move over to yearly from monthly
and select the $60 membership and then
you can apply the coupon code 2019 that
will drop a $60 membership to just
$20.19 okay we've had over 400 new
members sign up in January so far using
that coupon code and it's going away
it's going away very soon certainly
before my birthday
because we'll probably do some kind of
birthday special and we don't want to
overlapping blockbuster membership
specials so check that out and if we get
just 9 more new members I will open up
the phone lines at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
okay let's see what we have going on in
terms of super chats today K sent a $5
super chat and she says I work at a
state government office giving snap and
welfare benefits it has been a horrible
week seeing people cry when I tell them
they may not eat yeah it's absolutely
disgusting what's going on K and this is
now is I don't even know if the if this
is the longest shutdown ever or the
longest shutdown in modern history but
it has gone far longer than even my
friends in government who are in under
the Department of Homeland Security who
aren't getting paid expected this to go
and when you consider I mean listen for
let's forget for a second about the
people who are going hungry because that
that's an that's one level and that is
inconceivable in this country even aside
from that I believe it's 78 percent of
Americans are under what we would call
generally speaking a paycheck to
paycheck situation meaning that any kind
of significant unexpected expense or
and/or interruption of their source of
income very quickly becomes an emergency
right there was a study that we talked
about maybe a year ago or something like
that which pointed out that I believe it
was 40
set of Americans or no I think it was
60% of Americans would be unable to deal
with an unexpected $400 expense so I
mean it's what's a understand that this
is mostly impacting government workers
and those who receive benefits from
certain programs including food stamps
just because it's not affecting most
Americans doesn't mean it's not
affecting some Americans in an extremely
significant and acute way and I
genuinely at this point of no idea how
long it's going to go on for and you
know as a progressive who is sympathetic
and empathetic to people and what's
going on in the world on the one hand I
want government reopened as soon as
possible period at the same time the
recent proposal that Donald Trump made
where in exchange for roughly 1.6
billion plus 2,750 new border agents in
law enforcement plus 75 new judge teams
and a 5.7 billion for the wall he would
do three years of an extension on daca
and temporary protected status that that
quite frankly is a [ __ ] proposal
right he took that stuff away to begin
with he is the one who would suffer the
political consequences from starting to
deport the children of undocumented
immigrants so-called dreamers daca
recipients and he is he's the
Republicans I think know that that's not
something they can do the political
consequences would be absolutely huge
and it's just such a bogus proposal that
I don't think Democrats should accept it
but I do want government reopened as
soon as possible and I don't necessarily
know how to parse that because it's an
emergency for people as you're pointing
out Kay mr. [ __ ] zero 486 how much
backlash will there be in the Democratic
Party if a corporate friendly Democrat
wins the primary would it kill the
progressive movement no it wouldn't kill
the progressive movement but it would be
a disappointment and you know I think
what's very important to remember I mean
listen let's go back to the results that
we just got here
the difference for me between a
candidate that I know I very much agree
with like Democrat Andrew yang Kirsten
Gillibrand I still have some questions
about it I don't know why she came up so
high but Elizabeth Warren the difference
between Yang and Warren and someone like
Michelle Obama for example is the
difference between 77 and 88 or 77 and
84% we're on the same page on most
issues and I hate this phrase throw the
baby out with the bathwater I don't know
but but I think it sort of applies here
the opportunity to defeat Donald Trump
the opportunity to start writing some of
the embarrassingly horrible wrongs that
have surfaced as a result of the
destruction of relationships with allies
pulling out of the Paris climate deal
all sorts of stuff starting to fix that
as soon as possible is so much more
important than are we 100 percent 90
percent or 80 percent in agreement with
the winner of the Democratic primary I'm
not even a Democrat right I'm an
independent who is progressive and just
votes for whoever I assess to be most
most assess to be most in line with my
views nee omec doom with a dollar
ninety-nine it's the longest ever David
okay so the current shutdown is indeed
the the longest ever and at this point I
think we're in to potentially week five
so yeah it's I I don't know what the
what the what the end date is is even
potentially going to be at this point
but it's it's bad and I hope it gets
opened but Democrats should not cave
okay Nancy Pelosi is doing the right
thing here and I believe that as soon as
maybe it's tomorrow that Mitch McConnell
is going to bring up Donald Trump's
proposal as a bill in the Senate and
we'll see what happens but I do believe
that the Democrats should should reject
it let me do a couple more thank yous
here we've got a couple new members who
just signed up Paul Lundqvist
is a new David Pakman show member and
John Spano is a new david pakman show
member that
three new members during the livestream
I set at the top of the stream I'm glad
to open up the phone lines and take some
phone calls if people want but I would
like to get 10 new members or patrons ok
patreon for $1 a month you can become
one of those 10 it does cost us money
when we take phone calls the
infrastructure we have the handles up to
like 200 lines at once every time I take
phone calls for a half hour 45 minutes
an hour cost us money and a that's why
we're doing a membership challenge we
are three tenths of the way there three
new members looking for 10 coupon codes
are available there in the video
description would love to take some
phone calls but if people don't people
aren't interested people don't want me
to I don't I don't have to do it it's
not completely necessary
the other thing by the way which we
could do I don't know if people are
interested but I would consider taking a
couple of challenges on Leach s org I've
played against people in the audience a
couple of times people are usually much
better than me I'm David Pakman on Leach
s and I would be up for playing a game
or two if people wanted but really I'd
mostly like to hear from from people in
the audience and see what's going on and
how your I side with results went and
all of that stuff so we'll see what
happens and what we get okay let me take
a look at what's going on in the general
chat here and see what people are saying
a Bernie would win in a landslide I
don't know that we know that although I
love Bernie and supported him in the
primary in 2016
David gets owned in chess every time I
actually have won a couple of games on
stream but you know I'm not that good so
having to explain my moves while I play
makes me even worse people saying that
they would like to call in but they
don't know the number well I would give
the number if we end up taking phone
calls let's see what else David I'm a
Muslim socialist reptilian Illuminati
all right well good for you
David's a liberal Trump 2020 okay the
progressive voice is a package
any leftist but he doesn't criticize
Islam what a failure and a hack o
progressive voices in the channel why is
why is everybody going after progressive
voice David's not a socialist either he
said that's true I'm not white give the
progressive voice a break I don't know
why people are attacking him when is
David's birthday February 2nd Biden's a
robot Biden always sucked Biden is
beyond bad hmm is David an elitist
coffee drinker yeah I think some first
lady is not a qualification to be
president I guess that's in reference to
Michelle Obama fair enough but
accomplished attorney
I think Gillibrand and Harris Oprah
Winfrey will give everyone a free car
the test seems bad David you're a beta
male um progressive voice is a joke man
progressive voice is just getting
crushed here David can curse yeah I
don't curse on the regular show because
we are on two hundred broadcast radio
and television stations and once we had
a fleeting expletive leak and we got
emails from them pointing out that they
could get in trouble for that so we're
not doing that anymore
whoa this is a name says for $4.99 I
wish I understood the significance of
$4.99 versus $5.00 I don't know where do
you stand on universal basic income and
in general where do you think automation
and AI will take our society okay so I'm
for you bi although I've also mentioned
that I would be in principle okay with a
negative income tax as well different
proposals when I interviewed Andrew yang
he had thoughts on why he believes ubi
is better although he's not against a
negative income tax so I'm in favor of
ubi
here's my answer to where do I think
automation and a I will take society
automation and AI are not going to be
definitively good or necessarily bad for
society what's going to determine
whether in effect automation and AI are
good or bad for society is whether we're
ready to have the difficult conversation
okay the difficult conversation is we
need to rethink the relationship of
humans to work okay
difficult as a conversation because
people are because of their economic
views or we could call them
socio-economic views often very very
attached to either capitalism some form
of it or some other ideology and the
truth is that once you have significant
automation doing more and more jobs you
just need to rethink that relationship
like should it be a requirement for
people to work a full-time job in order
to be able to support themselves or can
automation sort of free us from that
requirement and say we recognize the
value of all sorts of activity even if
it doesn't have a specific dollar value
of economic benefit that you can attach
to it and arthur c clarke has written a
lot of science fiction that sort of
dances around this topic or even deals
with it more directly childhoods end
which was turned into a series that was
okay but the book is fantastic deals
with that and that's what's ultimately
going to determine the impact of
automation and AI on our society beans
Marto chia with a five-dollar super chat
since food stamps are being affected i
think it's an at we want the other
affected our Social Security recipients
going to be affected as far as I know
not in the immediate but there is a way
that in the long term there could be an
impact on Social Security benefits I
actually don't remember I read a piece
about it but from what I remember it was
sort of far off but I believe that there
is a mechanism through which certain
social security could be impacted by the
shutdown but I think it's significantly
significantly further off okay let me
say thanks to jean-luc Deroche who is
the newest david pakman show member
signing up at david pakman.com slash
membership thank you jean-luc that is
for we will open the phone lines if and
when we get ten new members or
subscribers and Hanley who was a new
patron earlier has also now become a new
david pakman show member that makes
five out of ten five out of ten new
members and patrons we are looking for
10 and I will open the phone lines at 6
1 7 8 3 0 47 50 don't be shy plenty of
coupon codes available 2 of them are in
the video description this is 20 20 will
save you 40% off of the membership of
your choice
20 19 will drop a $60 a year membership
all the way down to $20.19 we're halfway
there the phone lines are ready to go
but we will hopefully get those 10
subscribers and then get those phone
lines opened up okay a couple things in
the regular chat I wanted to mention
someone says they will make a prank call
if we open up the phone lines I have
been trolled a hundred times on the
phones and if you think I'm scared of a
prank call I hate to break it to you but
I'm not and I welcome it
universal basic income is a Silicon
Valley scam designed to prolong the pain
of capitalism's death I address that
with Andrew yang actually in our
interview and I would encourage you to
check that out what time is the normal
show to call okay so our normal call
time is Wednesdays at 1:15 p.m. eastern
US time we will be taking calls tomorrow
at that time David you should watch
Dragon Ball Z yeah I still don't know
what that is terrible picture of you
David oh I guess people mean wait which
picture is it this picture here oh I
don't know that it's that bad I mean
something very very strange was
happening with my hair on this day I
remember when this picture was taken
it's also a 30 year old picture which is
crazy imagine that but I don't think
it's the worst picture in the world
hey David do you think Bernie will run I
think he will David you're holding us
hostage by requiring new memberships in
order to open the phone lines come on
I've already addressed that that's bogus
tulsi has a bad track record don't be an
affected snob
tulsi is not an Islamophobe
Dave why do people believe Trump flies
well we've talked about that a cognitive
dissonance is a big part of it hey David
just saw an ad good to see ads are
coming back for the Pakman Channel yeah
you know they're I haven't done this in
a live stream like for over a year but
there's this button called play ad I'm
just gonna hit it and see what happens
okay tell me if you're getting an ad it
says your stream isn't currently live
that doesn't make sense we're live right
now how can it say I can't play an ad
because the stream is not live no okay
now it says that it is it is showing as
interesting yeah I've never I've never
really done that before okay uh anyway
let me say thanks to a sixth new member
Rex Woodham Rex I think I mean Rex
Woodham yeah six out of ten all right so
if we want to open the phone lines we
are just for new members or patrons away
and then I will go ahead and get those
phone lines open we had last time we did
this I was able to take I think it was
like close to 20 phone calls or
something like that maybe I'm
misremembering but it was a very very
big phone call day but if people don't
want that then we don't oh okay we've
got a seventh new member
Ross Hernandez 7th new member roster
Nanda's three more we can do three more
members let's just do it and get these
phone lines open right why not I feel
like that there's there is demand for
this let me tell you what's on
tomorrow's program just while we're
hanging here in case people are
interested let me pull up my stories
I've been working very very intensely on
tomorrow's program let me pull it up
here tomorrow is the 23rd okay so on the
program tomorrow we will talk about the
new claim I guess we would call it from
two House Democrats that there is a plan
to investigate Brett Kavanaugh for
perjury that would be very very
interesting I would love to see what
happens if there is an active house
investigation into a sitting Supreme
court justice so we will talk about that
tomorrow and I hope it happens we will
talk about what may be a coincidence or
it may not be after Donald Trump very
haphazardly announced that the United
States is leaving Syria we started
seeing Eric Prince the former CEO of
that mercenary film a firm Blackwater
and also happens to be the brother of
Secretary of Education Betsy DeVos Eric
Prince started showing up on CNN on Fox
Business in other places saying you know
what we should bring our troops home but
we've got to protect the Kurds so I have
the solution
let's send mercenaries from his own I
guess it's now been renamed Academy is
the new name of the former former
mercenary firm Blackwater let's send
them there and this is yet another new
layer we talked about the possibility of
Turkey and Saudi Arabia and the cash og
killing being related to Donald Trump's
haphazard decision to leave Syria we
talked about the Russia Bashar al-assad
element as possibly connected to Trump's
abrupt decision and lo and behold now we
have a guy in Eric Prince who is
connected to Donald Trump directly via
or almost directly via Trump's cabinet
and Betsy DeVos his sister and stands to
make an insane amount of money from
sending mercenaries to replace American
military in Syria and this is a trump
problem Trump's corruption this is also
bigger picture a military-industrial
complex problem we're gonna be talking
about that on tomorrow's program also
Donald Trump we learned walked out of a
policy meeting with Paul Ryan a few
months ago when Ryan was still in office
to go and watch television this is just
an absurd insane story where we've now
heard from from one of the former deputy
White House communications directors
Trump after about 15 minutes of Paul
Ryan just explaining stuff to him got up
and went to watch TV in his private
dining room and Mike Pence had to go and
get Trump and bring him back and this is
the this is the 88 ADHD presidency I
don't know don't know how else to say
all of that and more on tomorrow's show
okay let's get to a couple of other
super chats let me also thank Elijah
Jones Elijah Jones has signed up for a
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership that's 8 new members and
patrons during the stream to more and I
will open the phone lines at 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 50 ok I don't have all night to hang
but I will take some phone calls if we
get to more members and get to 10 at WWN
pakman.com Sabrina Zafar is a new
YouTube member that is another option
that is on the table why don't we count
that let's just count I mean that's a
type of membership let's count Sabrina
which pushes us to now in new members
and I don't know what that chime was
related to maybe Sabrina's membership so
one more member at WWE pakman.com and
that will call that 10 and I will open
up the phone lines black way 54 with a
$9 $0.99 super chat your what's with
this transgender thing going on and what
can it affect gang gang yeah so the
Supreme Court has upheld the legality of
Donald Trump's transgender military
service member ban and this is one that
is it's it's crazy to discriminate
against transgender people obviously at
the same time I don't want anyone to
have to be a tool of the US military and
the neocon Warhawk political use of the
military that we've seen by so many of
our presidents but you still shouldn't
be able to single out transgender
service members and for the time being
the Supreme Court is saying that that is
a policy that can go forward now we
still don't know what the implementation
of it will be is the military going to
start some kind of a seek and remove
policy or idea with to to figure out who
is trans
and to kick them out of the military
will they be honorable or dishonorable
discharges which has a big impact on
future job prospects there's there's a
bunch of obvious problems with the
transmen trans service member ban we
pointed them out in detail might have
been a year and a half ago at this point
when this policy was first announced by
Donald Trump and of course the Pentagon
at the time said we're not doing
anything differently for now we don't
know anything about this so that's
what's going on it conceivably would
allow some application of a ban on trans
military servicemembers which would be
extraordinarily stupid and also very
very bigoted but I don't I genuinely
don't know how you implement it you can
say well anyone who has had transition
surgery or other medical treatment paid
by the military I guess you could find
some record of that and you could
identify an initial group of people that
way but okay that doesn't apply to
everybody a lot of people don't do that
are they actually going to start looking
around for trans military service
members I have no idea but it's an
absolutely horrible and disgusting
policy D Ken from UCLA with $100 super
chat the biggest super chat of the
evening D Ken thank you so much really
appreciate it d ken says can you explain
the national debt
I keep hearing different figures from
Dems and Republican leaders the last
three years what are the negative
consequences of a high debt okay very
good questions so when you say can I
explain it the national debt is the
cumulative amount of deficits and
surpluses over the years okay this is
something a lot of people on the right
don't understand if on let's say you
start a country okay the first year you
run a deficit of a hundred bucks after
that year that first year you spent a
hundred dollars more than you took in
you ran a hundred dollar deficit after a
year you're running total debt is $100 I
think that part everybody basically gets
imagine that in year
- you run a hundred dollar deficit again
so in the second year that you are a
country you spend $100 more than you
take in that hundred dollar deficit gets
added on to the hundred dollar debt that
the country had at the beginning of that
second year your debt is now $200 $100
was the deficit for that year and your
debt went up to $200 now imagine that in
year three you run a fifty dollar
surplus and here's where you can imagine
how over the years politicians can play
games with this year three you start the
year with $200 in national debt and you
run a fifty dollar surplus you now have
reduced your debt from $200 to 150
dollars presuming that the $50 surplus
was actually used to pay down the debt
which is not a guarantee - interest okay
so I'm really simplifying here but your
fifty dollar surplus doesn't eliminate
the debt it could potentially pay it
down from 200 to 150 dollars the way
that's one way that politicians mess
with this which is by deliberately
flipping between debt and deficit and
also you know that there's so many ways
they can mess with it but another one is
talking about the rate of change in the
growth or reduction of the deficit
versus the absolute change so you might
have a president who comes in imagine
that in the last two years the previous
president saw the deficit grow in one
year by 20% and in the next year by 25%
you sometimes will have a new president
come in and say we've seen a reduction
in deficit growth of 50% you think whoa
hold on a second what through a
reduction in deficit growth what does
that mean what that might mean is that
the next president came in and
experienced deficit growth of twelve and
a half percent okay remember last year
for the previous president there was
twenty five percent deficit growth by
reducing the growth rate from 25 percent
the twelve
half-percent you can now tell I slowed
down deficit growth by 50% but what does
that actually tell us the debt still
continues to grow so these are just some
of the ways Dee can that you can mess
with that objectively speaking you can't
really just say these are the negative
consequences of a high debt modern
monetary theory and other economic
theory increasingly is telling us that
the Republican game of just saying debt
is bad period is it's it's a rused what
matters is why did we go into debt what
was the debt used to pay for and that's
ultimately what determines the economic
impact of it sir Edie Akhmed Yehia with
a $10 super chat why do we as a secular
nation support Israel's right for that
land that it claims it has only for
religious reasons because they're Jewish
and vice versa for any other religion
well what's important to remember is
that there's a lot of propaganda around
that issue and the creation of the State
of Israel was not on the basis of
religion in and of itself right and in
fact the the the founders of the State
of Israel were overwhelmingly
non-religious Jewish socialists in many
cases so you'd have to ask someone who
has that religious underpinning to
defend that I never have because that's
not I'm not religious
and I believe Israel has a right to
exist on a completely secular basis
countries are created in three ways
acquiring land by war annexation which
basically means well actually annexation
can mean purchase or it can mean what
what Russia did in Crimea or
international decree international
decree is the method that was used to
create the State of Israel from land
that was at different points Jordanian
and British so you know I think that
there's a double standard applied where
people can use either the relative
recency of the creation of
State of Israel as a way to question its
validity as a country which is logically
invalid or they sometimes will use
disagreements with foreign policy as a
reason to question Israeli the existence
of Israel and of course you know I don't
know of other countries that people
question on the basis of foreign policy
disagreements so I think there's a lot
of double standards and I don't I don't
think that a religious claim to the land
is necessary or interesting and I don't
uh I don't I don't support one skit City
oh oh one says hey David will you do any
more constitutional originalist debates
or economic policy debates sure I'm not
a constitutional scholar so I don't know
that I'm the right person for a
constitutional originalist debate but
I'm glad to do debates around economic
policy for for sure if people if people
want depends you know who who it is that
that people want me to debate and you
know the thing about debates is a lot of
times people want debates with issues
that I'm either not proficient in or
don't care about that much and it's a
debating for the sake of the bay
debating is not super interesting to me
okay we've gotten a few more new members
so let me open up the phone lines here
and then we can start taking I don't
have a crazy amount of time but I'll
take a few phone calls the number is six
one seven eight three zero forty seven
fifty if people want to call in and
start getting getting on hold and then
we will be able to take those calls I'll
give that a couple of minutes I will
thank even Hicks and David rouse a ruse
who has signed up as well as I think
that's it yeah those are the two new
members we have gotten over the 10 new
member mark for the stream so I will
I'll take some calls like I promised
we'll see who is who is interested in
talking to me today let's see here okay
looks like a lot of people are
interested in talking today let's go to
okay I'm telling you right Dante we're
not picking up on you today okay Dante
is very very
quick on the draw you've called it a
bunch of times a lot of people get very
angry when Dante gets on so we're not
picking up on Dante today let's go to
the six one zero area code caller from
six one zero what's going on David isn't
me that is you my friend uh hi this is
Justin um I had a question just trying
to take basically healthcare on a state
level in that sort of aspect I was
thinking about basically funding it by
by declaring that declaring that health
is a is a as part of defense and
basically asking for our proportion be a
per state I mean what would you think as
has to go that way maybe tell us a good
health care for all I'm not sure exactly
what you mean are you just simply saying
what do I think about pushing for health
care for all at the state level and
going about it that ways that would I
apologize I don't think I fully
understood your question okay yeah well
I I thought about this during the
election at first I was basically like
if we can't do it the one way go via
state and basically ask for a percentage
of what is spent on defense
are you saying that the state would ask
the federal government for a percentage
of that's been spending so then at the
state level make single-payer happen
yeah yeah I just don't know I don't
think that would ever work I don't know
how you do that I think that the idea of
states doing single-payer is a great one
I mean in Massachusetts we've been doing
our own thing called Romney care on
which Obama care was heavily based for
years it's not single-payer but it's
it's its own system so I like the
state-level idea you're not going to get
federal government defense money for
state-level single-payer though yeah
just an idea
okay thank you very much all right yeah
I mean I like that you're thinking about
it I just practically speaking don't
think don't think it would work okay
let's see
502 area code caller from 502 go ahead
hey what's going on David
I'm Scott this from Kentucky hey no
better than watching yourself for a
while I watch a lot of fun it's actually
from all sides the special bit of
athletics interest so anyway I was
wondering if you thought this shutdown
as maybe building up to something bigger
like a between border security and my
fault
for the for the dreamers that you think
that you know instead of this 5.7
billion for different sections of the
wall it's just they're gonna they're
gonna instead change it to like you know
it's full twenty or thirty billion for
all the security and Border Patrol and
all of the wall coverage and the drones
and then the ground tunnel scanning and
in exchange for all of our our dreamers
get to live here in that line of the
free and we a and easier immigration
process for a cheaper visas and such
like that anything that maybe we're
building up to a more realistic
compromise though and happy for everyone
I've pointed out that I actually would
be open to that so I'm opposed to the
wall and I'm opposed to five point seven
billion in exchange for temporary
protected status and Dhaka protections
for an additional three years Trump took
that away now he's trying to give it
back but saying it's good but saying
that it's a even though it's good and he
wants it it's a negotiating point it's
crazy what's going on right now but I
would be up for something like two
billion for Trump to feel like he won in
exchange for permanent status for daca
recipients because that actually would
be a really good deal particularly
assuming that it was like some kind of
system that wouldn't be reversible
because of that two billion you know I
mean we to billions an insane amount of
money but at a certain point you would
say I would trade it for permanent
status so I think we could be building
to that although the only risk is that
any end any money at all is seen as such
a victory by Trump esteem though from
said we were gonna do the entire border
and Mexico would pay for it it's
obviously never happening but there's
the propaganda value of it but Dhaka
permanent status for daca recipients
would be such a big thing that I would
be inclined to seriously consider an
offer like that there's also like the El
Chapo act you know that uh the Ted Cruz
before though talked about seizing you
know the ironically seizing you know
drug lords money in it and they're using
it on the for security and other such
things oh yeah that one's gonna be a
little tougher to pull off but I think
you know I we'll see what the next well
if Democrats reject what's coming up in
the Senate supposedly tomorrow we'll see
what the next iteration of the of the
proposal is oh yeah well it's great
talking to you buddy yeah okay
Thanks appreciate the phone call thank
you so much let's go to the 4a0 area
code caller from 4-8 zero go ahead it's
miles from Arizona University of Arizona
but I wanted to discuss the Magga
Catholic high school kids incident I'm
well aware that there's a lot more than
just the kids but I was just wondering
like to the kids alone who do you think
is to blame because my roommate and I
were discussing it a little bit and we
think the fault lies on the parents
especially when you consider the fact
that this is a rural Kentucky Catholic
High School deep Trump country these
parents probably a rabidly pro-trump and
that ship and that Crow trumpism just
trickled down to the kids yeah I so I
don't know if you saw my story yesterday
about it but there's a lot of blame
don't go around here obviously these are
kids these kids aren't five right so
they have some agency and at this point
they are starting to sort of become
their own people in the world they're
not yet adults but they're also not
little kids the parents obviously are a
huge part of the behavior the chaperones
the fact that the school allowed a
delegation to go to what was supposed to
be I guess a pro-choice appro an
anti-choice rally a pro-life so-called
pro-life rally dressed like they're
coming from a Trump rally
there's a lot of problems here we also
found out that the kids were heckling
other people before but the black
Israelites are a problem and we now have
more video which shows us that it
appears to have been an option
to go and get in the middle of that
group of kids by the Native American
processor I mean I what I said yesterday
was I'm not ranking behavior I'm not
telling you every side is equal in this
thing but there's a lot of just toxic
politics and misbehavior to go around
here I mean yeah the whole thing it
definitely was a major mess um I guess
on a little bit of a different note if
you have time or
no or do you wanna miles we're
connection so bad and you're cutting in
and out that I'm gonna let you go but I
appreciate that question and I hope to
hear from you again let's go to the
eight one five area code caller from
eight one five go ahead hey what's going
on David a big fan but a member for a
while thank you
my question is I know there's some on
the left like a Kyle kolinsky Michael
Brooks they kind of brush the Russia
stuff to the side I noticed you don't do
that but why do you think some on the
Left kind of I don't want to say you're
not taking it serious but like I said I
kind of brush it to the side the Russian
investigation you know I I can't say
specifically with any one person and I
also you know I'm I'm going by what
you're saying about Kyle kolinsky and
Michael Brooks I don't really watch
almost anything so I don't know what
they've been saying to be quite honest
but I think there's a couple different
things going on excuse me one is there
are people on the Left who feel as
though the Russia story somehow props up
Hillary Clinton's candidacy and that
that might not make sense now two years
out but the idea is if Russia helped
Trump win then were it not for Russia
Hillary would have won and we don't like
the fact that Hillary might have won
because we think Hillary is not as good
as Bernie okay so that's like one
narrative I'm not saying that applies to
Kyle or Michael I don't know what their
arguments are others maybe are just of
the mindset that it doesn't make sense
to talk about it that it whatever it is
that's going on with Russia that there's
policy things to talk about and they
just don't think it's important to talk
about possible rampant criminality and
collusion with a foreign country to
seize the presidency I would simply
disagree in that case and I would agree
that there's lots of other things to
talk about and we can do both at the
same time but I think you'd have to ask
them I mean I'm not one of them you know
so I can't say what the what's in their
mind okay yeah all right no problem I
appreciate the phone call um let's see
here let's go to Brody Brody's holding
on we have a bunch of Brody caller so I
don't know which Brody this is David
David it is the Brody from Dallas that
you know what's up man what's going on
Brody
not much hey so I wanted to actually tap
your economic expertise because I'm
curious I've heard that Moody's has
stated but there are a lot of economists
who are concerned that there's going to
be at least a recession or some type of
slowdown within the next 18 months or so
and I want to know what you thought the
impact of the government shut down if it
continues for say another god forbid
four weeks or something will that have
an impact on whether or not we're going
to experience a harder economic slowdown
and do you see any kind of economic
slowdown or economic issues coming as a
result of that and also people who pick
up a discord link on reddit as well the
discord link on reddit okay so here's
the thing there's like a bunch of layers
to this one is economists and their
predictions are basically worth nothing
okay economists have been predicting a
slowdown sometime in the next one to six
years for like the last eight years okay
so that's that's number one and I don't
you know from a from a merely logical
standpoint you don't have just boom
cycles forever
so at a certain point there's going to
be a pullback and at a certain point
there's going to be a big enough one
that we would call it a recession of
some kind the idea that now we can say
with more certainty that it's in 18
months we're a day closer to the next
pullback than we were yesterday that's
what we can say and I don't really pay
much attention to these economists who
say now it's an 18-month thing or 12 or
24 months government shutdown if it goes
on too long it will start to affect the
economy it's not going to cause a
recession when there wouldn't otherwise
be one but it could exacerbate it
because you are talking about impacting
the total amount of government spending
which is a factor in terms of demand
side stimulus and also there will be
millions of people who will be impacted
between federal government workers
associated contractors and people who
aren't going to be getting food stamps
for example which are very economically
stimulative if airports get shut down
that will impact industry so it'll have
an effect but it won't create a
recession as far as airports getting
shut down - again one last question
would you avoid international travel if
you were me I guess or anybody like
would you avoid international travel but
now in march or like planning
international travel why what's
happening now in march i mean i guess i
guess with the shutdown continue like
would you know is the show got like is
that gonna hinder international travel
versus domestic travel i don't think so
i mean you're if you're flying out from
the US you're just you're going through
TSA no matter whether you're flying
domestically or internationally so i
don't think it makes a difference oh
alright cool i love the show man
okay thanks Brody great to hear from you
um let's see let's go to the two on five
area code caller from to15 you're on the
air
hello is this me that is you I uh well
first of all I just wanted to say I'm a
big fan of your show
Washington has you know made me
political politically Alok and active so
I do have two quick questions I'm gonna
try and get through them so I know you
just took the test about the candidates
and I just want to get your perspective
on how would you rank them and your
support of the world candidates
currently running and why so I mean as
I've said before I think Andrew yang is
awesome we have to be sort of realistic
that he's not at the same caliber in
terms of electability as Elizabeth
Warren but I'm not trying to play
electability games I'm just trying to
say who is the person I agree with the
most from what we would call the central
candidates right now I think if the
election were today I would I would
support Elizabeth Warren that would be
more than likely who I would support
today yeah I feel like I would probably
say the same thing but my argument would
be that I know Bernie had policies that
most people have read with but they
didn't get enough explosion I feel like
it might be the same issue with Andrew
yang
yeah I think that I'm going to do what I
can I'm gonna have Andrew yang back on
and I'm going to at least at this stage
do what I can to say this is someone who
is a really great candidate and has a
lot of the right ideas so I'm gonna try
to be a part of the solution and not the
problem there yeah and one last quick
question so what is your stance
on a six-hour workday because I know
Sweden had import experimented with it
in two years and there was you know
positive feedback from it and I know you
were talking about reworking the work
ethic in our country is anything wrong
with you know six-hour workday there
have been experiments with four-day work
weeks all of that stuff I think it
should be on the table for sure all
right well thank you very much again
great fan yeah keep it up
all right thanks really appreciate the
call I'll take a couple more calls but
let me get to these couple of super
chats
Cerreta Achmed Yehia wrote back saying I
do believe in Israel's right to exist
for Jewish people because they were
persecuted for hundreds of years but
like the land they live in right now at
some point belongs to someone else
yeah I mean that applies to most
countries and I don't know where that
necessarily gets us but you're right a
lot of countries now exist on land that
at some point was someone else's Roy
Earle says David did you hear that Dave
Rubin praised yeah your balsan are oh I
did also can you expand upon the story
about your meeting with Alex Jones at
that conference yes oh I'll tell this
story again because it's been a while
since I told it I met Alex Jones in
person one time I'm sure he doesn't
remember it it was at a talk radio
conference about ten years ago called
talkers new media seminar in New York
City and Alex Jones gave a speech he got
like the freedom of speech award or
something and then after that he
apparently knew we had some friends in
common there there were there's these
libertarian guys who used to have a show
they may stay although I'm not sure like
a libertarian show called free talk live
Ian Freeman and Mark edge and I guess
Ian and mark knew Alex so I was sort of
talking to mark and Ian and Alex Jones
came over at kind of the same time and
what suggested to me that he was playing
a character was he kind of said in a way
that was kind of like an you know
insider's club thing you know I could
have really freaked them out up there
but I decided not to sort of like what
he does is a character of different
degrees of wacky but it was very brief
and his wife who I've interviewed or
ex-wife I guess her soon to be a
wife told me it's not at all a character
so I don't know I mean it was it was a
very brief conversation and I don't know
how much we can really deduce from it
other than you know he sort of intimated
that he dials it up or tones it down
depending on what's going on art Flores
says if you were one of trumps lawyers
and help win the case against
obstruction of justice would you feel
personally wronged or would it be your
greatest accomplishment you know I am so
far from being the right person to
answer that question I am simply not I
couldn't even imagine of being one of
Donald Trump's lawyers let me take a
couple more calls and then I got a run
let's go to the five one two area code
five one two go ahead
um would that be me that is indeed you
okay well um okay so I know you're
probably tired of hearing about this
subject but I thought maybe I could add
something to it which subject um the
subject of race and IQ Oh Oh God okay
yeah that one uh well I was thinking
that maybe the racist element and have
subject matter and the part of it that
makes people so uncomfortable it's not
the idea itself that certain races have
lower IQs but sort of the implied threat
of what would happen to them what they
did and how the ride would use that like
I think that's the word well there's an
intermediate step I think that you're
skipping which is it's not so much that
different races do differently well on
one test that exists but the idea that
number one it's a good indicator of all
types of intelligence and more
importantly number two that it's linked
inherently to the race of the people
right so here and this is the example
that I find to be the most illustrative
here the race in IQ people like to talk
about Asian people but they also like to
talk about
Ashkenazi Jews right Ashkenazi Jews
great IQ all okay whatever the basic IT
IQ test is very closely correlated with
verbal abilities and we had a situation
on planet Earth
for hundreds of years you had Ashkenazi
Jews who were literally not allowed to
hold many jobs and ended up in
circumstances were one of the things
that they could do no one could really
stop them from doing this or they tried
but they didn't succeed was they would
sit around and read and study often
religious texts but also other things
rhetoric and debating and all this type
of stuff and on the other hand you had
black Americans who for a long period of
time would be killed if they read books
or or even tried to learn how to read
imagine for a second if you took two
hundred years and reversed it and you
made it so that it was illegal for Jews
to read but all black Americans did was
sit around reading books and learning
rhetoric and debate and all of this sort
of stuff does anyone realize I think
that the IQ tests would come out the
same way I mean the real I'll tell you
I'll tell you I've looked at it and see
I had a lot of trouble with this issue
area and I really did not want there to
be a correlation and I just feel like if
that were really all that it was that
the statistics would swill be a little
different and we'll see black America do
better on the tests but once again
that's just my family I watched your
video about it and that's just my
opinion right now but once again I think
this kind of it goes along with us about
critiques of capitalism and stuff like
why do we live in the 21st century when
we did it you know we have this much
money and we can help people and we
could even potentially have universal
basic income why why would that even
matter if there was like a phenotype
like skin color that correlated with
something like IQ like why are people so
afraid of that I don't think we should
live in the country where people where
they feel like there will be a
punishment or they have to be afraid of
performing a certain way in one aspect
and performing another way why not yeah
I don't disturb you to it I don't
disagree with you but it sounds like
you're saying you think there is
something inherent to race a night well
I don't think the guy understands it the
concept of race is um I mean what what
is that even mean racing aren't you like
I mean I think there's a little
I just feel like there's a little
something [ __ ] I don't know um I just
don't understand it yeah that's my that
was my main point about it I'm still
like looking trying to discover the
issue and looking at different ways and
start our lecture how I believe about
can I ask you why how did this issue
become so important to you um I am
actually I don't know what the term is
biracial
I'm one-fourth african-american Wow so
because you're 1/4 african-american you
became very interested in race in IQ yes
okay all right sounds good
I appreciate the call I don't think I
have too much else to say about it I
think you know it's it's become a very
boring topic quite frankly to me okay
let's go to the 209 area code and 209
just hang with me for a second here I do
have a ten dollar super chat from Surrey
deokman yahia who says consider this my
contribution I'm not a member keep up
the good work thank you for the 30 bucks
you've sent in tonight you could have
yourself a nice little membership and
all the benefits that go with it and Roy
Earle says David whatever happened to
one of your co-hosts Rachael she ended
up taking a job that was more closely
correlated with her field like two years
ago or a year and a half or something
like that I'm still in touch with her
and and she's doing great
2:09 area code go ahead all of you a big
fan of the show so my question regards
so usually the conservative answer to
problems regarding poverty tend to be Oh
get a job or work harder or clean your
room something like that so basically
the you know answer to a problem is to
not have that problem as opposed to
actually offering a solution okay and my
question is is there a way to move that
conversation forward because I don't
really see it listen if someone's
committed to just heartbeat I'll be so
okay you're talking about how to engage
with people who hold certain views you
have to distinguish between someone who
holds that view
because they believe they've been
reasoned into it and are willing to hear
reason as a way to get out of it or if
you're just dealing with ideologues who
are irrationally married to certain
talking points if it's the latter I
don't think there's anything you can
really say if it's the former you can
start it with a Socratic method of
questioning with what you're talking
about I think there would be a lot to
starting to say you know in the United
States if you're born rich you're very
likely to remain rich and if you're born
poor
you're very likely to remain poor what
do you attribute that to and then
sometimes they'll talk about you know
NBA basketball players or actors or
something like that and then you've got
to bring them back to reality and tell
them that's that's anecdotal for the
most part that you know there's low
mobility is your argument that poor
people give birth to more poor people
who are all lazy and that's why they're
poor and rich people give birth to
go-getters who also stay rich and it's a
meritocracy and it's very very hard to
defend that and that can sometimes cause
like an initial crack that then you can
use to gonna get into more detail but
again if people are committed to some of
these ideas you're not going to be able
to reason them out of it all right all
right I see okay well let you go get
dinner eat the Spanish tortilla and they
know Spanish tortilla tonight I think
tonight I'm making I'm making miso
glazed salmon but I'll keep you posted
on that Spanish tortilla recipe yes both
the video please like the Spanish
tortilla yeah yeah yeah no I know the
video it's a it's a doozy I'll tell you
okay thanks for the call appreciate it
let's go to a caller from the six one
seven area code because it could be a
local caller here from Boston what's
going on Oh 6 1 7 that's you you sound
like you're underwater can you it can
you get above water or maybe do
something so I can hear you better oh
sorry I was wondering if you think
there's gonna be a more reasonable
Republican my Kasich that would
challenge Trump in the primary
oh yeah
think there will be a primary challenger
at the Trump and I think they will be
more reasonable but I don't really think
they're gonna stand much of a shot
okay thank you all right very quick call
that was an easy one okay let's go to
the nine one seven area code caller from
nine one seven go ahead oh that is you
uncle I'm wondering when when do you
think the shutdown will end and how I'll
end it will end on March 3rd I mean
rather in like terms of like next month
next week
yeah March 3rd oh wow it's quite one
thank you yeah
no I'm kidding I I have no idea I really
don't I I think this thing could go on
or you know I think you could easily go
on another month
whoa it's just I threw my sharpie I
apologize I think it could easily go on
another month and I don't know
ultimately what it will take to end it I
don't know which side is going to blink
first it's like a game of chicken I have
no idea all right thank you okay no
problem
very good he seemed just as satisfied
with my real answer as to the fake one
okay I've got a run thanks to everybody
who joined me today become members be
good people who support independent
media you will have your name set on the
show and it's all going to be fantastic
and we will take calls again and we'll
do more streams in the future